a man the police got it he said us hold
on wait no the police got you you said I
just told them who you were
why would you tell Nick Darnell Dockett
are you doing man good to see you man
your turn to break and go here man it's
you against the other ones last time you
played so let's go lift up no I'm good
and a lot of things Poole is not my
strength so if I don't make a good hit
the first ball that pop off the wall and
hit first one this is not my script or
judgment
so 2008 had a great run with the
Cardinals leading up to the NFC
Championship game against the Eagles
what were you doing that Friday I was
living my best life I mean the first
time I ever been into the NFC
Championship game feeling good healthy
Kurt one is probably reading his Bible
going over plays Larry probably getting
his feet done no Adrian James probably
it's no we're betting somebody in and me
I'm on a damn four-wheeler doing
anything I want to do you got telling
what happened that some of the story so
me and Antonio Smith was like brothers
we like the movie Step Brothers and we
did pretty much everything together man
tones like let's go get four we lose
sounds like that come on we just go to
the stop shop
you had two limited edition
four-wheelers so why exactly did you get
a four-wheeler it was one of these
things when you're bored and you making
a lot of money and you look for things
to do in Arizona because it's not really
a lot to do so we get on the four
wheelers I called him I said Tony meet
me at the park up the street we're gonna
ride he's all right cool so I get on the
floor we ride through the neighborhood
and ride through the parks kids out at
the park I all through the street you
know get ready to play the NFC champion
again we where we go to the Super Bowl
we live on our best life
police cuffs damn I see him and the
first thing I'm thinking like we get in
trouble we done you know I'm saying I'm
telling him so he's like how we gonna
I'm gonna break we're not gonna ride
together who's gonna break turn around
come back across the school I see two
police officers sitting at the school
with their lights so now for the weird
we haven't chased now so I'm going down
the road I'll cut through streets and go
through back roads I get to my house I
go into how some panic calling Tony I'm
Chinese just make sure that you get
caught us up 15 minutes later my phone
ring tell me what happen when that phone
rang and Tony or coffee he says uh hey
Doc I said what's up man you good he
said a man the police got it he said oh
hold on wait no the police got you I
just told him who you were
why would you tell me oh how you doing
he said he said nah man they cool they
just want you to come on back and um we
probably go get a court date we don't do
what first of all so I was not there I
don't know what you talkin bout hung up
the phone then he calls back again and
say yeah man
I'm gonna give him your address so they
can just come by myself he said nah man
they cool it cool it's a total no
nothing not cool about ten minutes later
the police call and was like hey we need
you to come back around here I said for
what he said because he's riding another
four-wheeler and at this point I'm like
I gotta meet to it because if I don't
there's like me like so but he might
make the situation work yeah cuz I'm
gonna come over there but never meet
that I was on the phone I said I feel
worried I'm gonna get myself where you
located that he said at the same park he
was doing donuts said I'm like oh I
don't know I'm Antonia Toni oh hey wait
he's mourning me that he said the park I
knew where the party was obviously and I
get in the car man and it's like seven
police officers they all sitting out
there I came out and he was like um mr.
doctor
something me like yeah you got any ID on
you oh why do I got I do if you already
knows me Gooden he said Oh
what was y'all thinking y'all got the
biggest game of the year Arizona you
know we did try to go to the Super Bowl
whoosh I think what a morning I thought
these four-wheelers and we didn't have
you guys like we gonna let y'all go but
can't do us a favor my whole heart just
came from my we obviously played the
game mm-hmm that officer comes to my
house on Tuesdays not to the door and I
said what's going on you say thank you
for keeping your word congratulations
and I was like man I'm Ranma
four-wheeling before we put up we start
laughing about it still to this day man
so have a relationship a beer cool I'll
add some first time I'm a real
professional Jose right but you just
gotta move money on the line move things
in my way thanks for kicking you with us
subscribe to be our to check out more
dope videos like this one